nous allons retrouver dans quelques
instants une minute pour les femmes les
missions des lianes victor mais
auparavant j'aimerais vous rappeler nos
principaux rendez vous de la soirée
tout d'abord à 19h45 nous pourrons
suivre le dixième épisode du feuilleton
de jean-pierre richard iii de coeur à
20h30 nous irons au théâtre pour voir
une comédie en noir et blanc de gabri à
la roue déjà diffusée le 4 juin 1970 et
intitulé deux fois deux fonds 5 et les
quatre acteurs que nous retrouverons
seront alain pralon michel grellier
michel roux et colette castel puis après
la dernière édition de tf1 actualité
c'est à dire à 22h45
nous irons à montréal pour assister en
direct à diverses épreuves des jeux
olympiques mais pour le moment je cède
la place à anne marie peysson
oh